foreign
how tall is he is you can go ahead and
step up
uh almost 45 45
bucks you're 45 bucks tall
I'm gonna go ahead and check his blood
pressure okay
so that was an inside joke because
um taika loves saying naughty words
and we'll tell them not to say it of
course but he's also the king of
loopholes like me of course so what he's
been saying because he likes to say
butthole so you can't say butthole he's
been saying 45 bucks whole
and we're like um that's too close buddy
and so anytime we hear the word 45 it
rings the bell and both me Gio and taika
so when she said 45 I was like 45.
bucks
so as you can see we are at the doctors
two weeks ago we brought taika back in
to get his little brain scan what is
that called EEG EEG because
um taika unfortunately had his fourth
seizure and
um I'm really grateful and really
appreciative of all of you guys that
continuously check in because I know
there's a lot of other parents who also
have kids that have seizures and so when
you guys explain their stories and I
even read it in the comments
um it kind of normalizes it a little bit
you know and it makes it feel like not
so crazy and it's cool that a little
Community going on so I really really
appreciate that so I wanted to just
update you guys on what's been going on
so yeah we increased his medication
and we thought that would stop it and it
did for a few months but he got his
fourth episode so now we're like okay
what is going on so we have to get his
low brain rescanned and today we're
gonna get the results
and hopefully
um we can find some answers soon because
it's very scary for him and scary for us
because every time we get our phone
rings during the day we're like oh my
goodness is it the school
and um let me go pick him up like he's
always throwing his words he's crying he
doesn't know where he's at he's
discombobulated and just just feels so
bad so hopefully we find some answers
today is Mr Hat what in the
what was that
hey you got four tails growing out dude
you got four tails
can you believe this guy gets seizures
that's the crazy part like he's so happy
and so goofy but anytime his whole body
could just shut down like that and
that's the nutso's part
a
scary monster yeah yeah
I thought you were gonna say dress up
like Leonardo or Donatella
no
um
you could already dress up like that in
the pants
no
that's very popular
good job can you touch my finger
just like this one finger touch my
finger no do it with the other hand
good now stick your arms out like this
all the way up close your eyes
good job very good now do me a favor
look at look at the minion that is
waving at you okay
cool thank you look at that look at Bob
yep and it looks like your dad likes to
work the camera so he'll be in charge
yeah and then I'll see you back here
I'll see you back here after
ah you know it takes a while for those
EEG so I'll probably see you in December
okay December yeah you got one of those
wires on your head Mister for a whole
day just one day for one day can you
handle that
[Music]
hey that's to do with the wires
oh yes
[Music]
okay
all right so good news is the EEG scan
um came back normal and that's the
second time so I confirmed that
the bad news part of that is that
doesn't give the doctor any additional
information so right now the medication
that he's on it's for uh generalized
seizures so I believe it's called Keppra
and what that means is you can get like
General seizures or you can get really
focal seizures and depending on how
specific your seizures are they have
more specific medicine
so since the last time we got Keppra it
was like four milliliters or something
and we thought that would be because we
already bumped it up a dose from I think
like two or two point five we thought
that would be okay and that was going to
cover his seizures but we had the fourth
episode so now with the information
that's given because
um there's no additional information
from the EEG and the four isn't working
then they're gonna bump it up to the max
amount for his weight and he's a little
dude he's 45.
pounds 45 pounds and exactly 45 bucks
um
and you do do your homework and it's so
random and um so he's gonna be bumped up
to six now and that's the absolute
highest amount and so what the doctor
was referring to earlier in the video
when they're saying that he has to wear
like this uh these wires home the next
step is to get these 24-hour readings
where he has to wear for a whole day
just out and about and then he takes a
nap and all that and then hopefully that
gives us some information so we're just
gaining more information inch by inch
and uh we'll just keep updating you guys
on what we find out but that's all we
have so far
and um hopefully the additional six
milliliters works and we don't see any
more seizures one other thing that we've
been doing on our own is uh we found out
that like any type of lack of sleep even
though we put them to bed by 10 and he
always sleeps at least like eight hours
but any lack of sleep is a huge
contributor getting more seizures so we
put we've been putting him to bed by 8
30 now
um and so far with that and the medicine
we haven't seen more episodes so
hopefully with this new regimen
fingers crossed
um we'll see him seizure free all right
and another Milestone that I'm really
proud of this little monkey dude that he
can do now is he's been learning how to
spell
so check it out
monkey how do you spell
the
t-h-e good job how do you spell
C
um
wow how do you spell he
um
h e good job isn't that incredible like
for those of you guys have been
following us for a long time we've
literally seen a human get built right
before our eyes like starting with just
me and Joe as a couple
to him getting born to him learning how
to walk to him going to school to now
him like learning how to spell
that's crazy I'm so proud of you mister
you ready for your McDonald's
hello see Mama's right there with the uh
Barbara Brigade shirt
um because we're still on a diet so
we're getting some Chipotle action and
then there's a McDonald's right there
your Taco Bell you see a Taco Bell where
uh behind us are you sure yeah yeah I
think you're tricking me
what do you have there what is it dude
what is it in here can you pull out your
French fries
yeah here she'll pop out your French
fries oh
can I smell them
serious look how little they are let me
see let me smell them oh my
God
damn
oh my don't put it too close to your
mouth oh my damn don't say that why
what'd I say
oh my d-a-m-e but there was an emphasis
I see see it's so hard being a father
don't say that it's so hard being a
father we could go we used to get away
with it before turning on me dude we
were able to get away with it before
but now he's getting a little bit and he
knows how to spell all these words dude
these three little words hey t-h-e good
job
all right so we got uh
what is this my chips oh I was like dude
that's so light I was talking about fill
me up for nothing
did you get a burrito too yeah so we got
Chipotle Chipotle for some reason no
shade but never looks as appetizing I
love it it has what you love Chipotle I
like McDonald's
more than McDonald's why only get
hamburgers at McDonald's
fries yes but I hear I get like it's all
the same food I just get the salad or
the burrito I know that's so sad
McDonald's got fish fillet you got the
Double Quarter Pounder with Mac sauce
you got chicken nuggets why
something hey he knows what's up but you
like junk food and you get Coke today
oh God let me see here let me drink a
little bit I want to see your reaction
he loves soda
oh yeah and he never gets it that's why
he's so happy
like a gentleman
and he only gets it because we're
actually uh on our way to grandma's
house so so we'll be driving
um four hours to La so I just wanted to
make sure that he was like a CUNY little
happy camper and get him some Yummy
Yummies
she's like 40 years old dude what is
this a vet you look like you're rich she
said I'm rich did you hear that yeah you
look like a proud father dude like
you're so happy seeing your children up
front driving you around
foreign
thank you
thank you improv trip or something you
need to you need your own TV show I know
Mister yeah
so
the show on the road
got my little Maps going on it says
we'll make it back in time to La at 6
40. time for what and that's important
because we're having GEOS first uh
birthday dinner with her family so I'm
sure Jill's family is um really misses
me a lot so they can't wait to see me
for Geo's birthday and we got the little
dudes why are you looking at me like
that
oh my God dry so we got the little dude
set up back here so he's ready for his
little road trip
this little kiddo has been so good this
whole trip what are you working on right
now
let's do it his
homework he's even have homework really
I mean he does We read to him like every
night but it's just CUNY that we're
building this habit so now anytime he's
opening a book or writing or cutting or
doing anything he's doing homework so
we're in Barstow right now I don't know
why that word didn't want to come out uh
got a little coffee break because uh
getting a little bit tired just need a
little like booster rooski and I'm about
to get
on the road thank God for not seeing
crack a lacking like I like it when I
say crackle I don't know your booster
yeah all right all right tough guy
so what do you mean tough guys because
you saw his muscles on oh God that makes
me look tough huh
all right we made it and this little
monkey child is so excited to see his
cousins
no that's not their car but yeah we're
gonna eat at everything BJ's every
little kitty series
come here there's too many cars are you
gonna get uh
are you serious yeah BJs
I was baking on you getting it so I
could have some oh well someone will get
it okay because it's your birthday you
have to for you yeah for me
I've been eating good all day saving
some room okay so I can have a little
bit of bazooka Dukes that's my favorite
thing from beaches oh yeah
no just hug them just hug them
go hug the other one
[Music]
go hug the other one dude
look at these munchkins
it's the Three Musketeers
let's go inside dudes a little monkey
monkey children
okay let's go inside
[Applause]
your house
bye-bye see you later
we're stuck together
we're stuck together forever
Jill's mom's favorite
[Applause]
look at this CUNY table we have to sit
strategically what's the strategy to sit
down this guy oh yeah we got to keep a
watchful eye on him but we got the three
kids together that's all sitting on this
side so we have a dog conversations
thank you
hello
I want it I've been wanting it all
finished
oh you got a ribeyeless
secondhand french fries
oh my God
french fries and Ranch dude
dude dude look at all the CUNY kid food
you got a little tenders Burgers sliders
and a big old steak I want an A1 Sauce
this is what I got for dinner trying to
stay semi-healthy that's a rice pilaf
action roasted veggies
because uh maybe bad ribs and a looks
like a baby a baby trying to
show me that trick
like a little dog when you find their
spot
you big weirdo
sure look what he ordered
what where did that come from I was just
looking that way and I look over here
there's three of them oh my goodness
happy birthday
take it
[Music]
hey mama is your butt butt okay
barely
did you make it or did you [ __ ] yourself
you made it
good job Mama
um your mom says there's a
wipe is in the sink
your master there's wipeys in the sink
that's what happens when she gets ice
cream
she gets the bubble Gus I'm glad we made
it back in time
so that's where your abs looks like once
all the diarrhea comes out huh
son of a [ __ ] I was like
I have to poop and he goes we were on
the freeway I said I have to poop and
then he gets off the freeway while I was
following her brother
your brother knows his ways around here
and then you go Midway after like
the red light you're like yo you're
right this way is long well why did your
brother take it I'm just gonna follow
him because he doesn't have to poop
well he's taking the scenic route
of course the scenic East lost route
that's the non-poo brow
watch next time you have to poop I can't
wait one to Vlog in two take my sweet
ass time how come ice cream does that
too it's so funny I know I mean I don't
mind it I get to taste it and it comes
right out I wish that happened to me
because my body keeps all that stuff
okay you still got abs I know I don't
even know wow look at this
Kevin you may get clean bulk did you
have a nice family Kitty dinner of
course the only bummer was that you're
there I promise yeah did you tell him
what name you had the reservation under
no so this is in uh BJ's in Montebello
predominantly Latino yep
um demographic he reserves our table
of what was it
what the name
no it's actually under Barb I told your
brother that that would be fine oh my
God it was yeah hey look it's cute
they were waiting on my hung this
morning she goes we've been waiting
quite a bit why don't you guys just get
the table and she goes because we
couldn't see that
she said we can't sing that I'm like I'm
sorry Mom
and I made a bit with them I like how
it's so cute
hey hey what are these guys what are
these guys what are These Guys these
guys get you in trouble so much
did you show Grandma Cooper she saw him
yeah
oh my God Cooper why'd you do that to
taika
[Music]
took a shower
feel nice and relaxed
in my home sweet home in L.A
how are you feeling bikini
they have some privacy please
and just like that
good night everyone